we got these weird sort of skewed dice
like usual Dicer cubes right these are
not these are kind of squished somehow
all that well it's a bit there a little
bit sort of eldritch or like a cult or
distorted from the fourth dimension or
something and what's the first question
well the first question is are they fair
are they fat well that's rollin and find
out shall we
I don't know yeah that looks fair to me
yeah well so you know they work just
like ordinary dice and right are they
fit well okay this is an ordinary dice
so it's as your you know your usual cube
shaped dice so why why do you think this
is fair like what is it about it that
makes it fair it seems very symmetrical
and it all the sides seem the same area
right right yeah so so so really the the
reason why you know this thing I mean
it's not actually fair because you know
there's different like the six dents
taken out of this and there's wondering
you know or forgetting all that suppose
it was an ordinary you know just a
perfect mathematical cube physics sort
of messes things up in it and it makes
things you know bounce around in some
crazy way and you want to know that
there's no bias right so so here's a way
to think about like what is it that
makes this fair so if I sort of take
this away and erase all the faces and
write new ones on and give it back to
you you wouldn't be able to tell that I
done anything because it's got these
sort of symmetries that I can like move
this around so it's about the symmetry
it's about like you know I guess the
three is the same as the five because
you can move the thing to change the
five into the three but it doesn't
change the shape of it okay so now I got
these things so all I have to do is
convince you that that all of the faces
are the same that the symmetries that
take any to any others so there you go
like so you can see the threefold
rotational symmetry here like very
rotate it like that it's the same and
then the three on the back if I do this
they're also the same so they're all the
same as well it's got the same so the
property is called I so he'd rule I so
he'd rule is the property of a
polyhedron which is like the symmetries
move the faces to you can move any face
to any other face
I can rotate 120 degrees I created 20
degrees again whoops and then I can do
this switch around thing here so these
have like just enough symmetry these are
the mental amount of symmetry you can
have to be fair whereas your ordinary
cube has excessive amounts of symmetry
you could say right I mean this there's
weight there's extra symmetries like
this thing is the same as it's the same
shape but like I haven't it's still face
to right so this has way more symmetry
than you need and this adds just enough
to be fair this is a symmetry of the
cube that doesn't make it any more fair
right the two is still the two whereas
this thing there's nothing you can do
that doesn't sort of mean right to
anything I can do to this that's a
symmetry it means that you know it moves
some face to some other face showing
that you know and you need that for it
to be fair so all the things are like
necessary here okay so we have like six
sided dice and people have seen like
10-sided dice and 20-sided dice how far
can you go right so well if you want a
fair die right so this is a sixty sided
die which has the same sort of symmetry
properties as we were talking about
before every face is the same as every
other ones here's phase twenty-four
right and I guess I've got face what's
the opposite opposite of twenty-four
because they have to add up to 61 right
because that's what you do on on dice of
24 there's 37 you turn it around and I
guess maybe you have to turn it upside
down again and then it makes it the same
the same shape after you're done so 24
is the same as 37 you do that with any
all the other one other ones here one
problem with this is that is really
round so kind of rolls forever so I'm we
can try and do it like yep there we go
one you're out that that's it that's a
critical fail I think on a d60 this one
you're showing me now looks kind of fair
again just right one have excessive
symmetry or as this one as bare minimum
well it's getting tough like when you
get to sixty sides like
like you've run out of kind of
symmetries that you can do there's one
extra symmetry this house that isn't
necessary in some sense which is the
reflection right so like you can see a
line of a mirror symmetry there so there
is a way there is a I so he drew a
polyhedron that has the symmetry thing
with 60 sides
the only problem like I really wish we
could have done this the only problem is
that it doesn't have opposite sides
parallel so when it lands on the table
there isn't an obvious face that's up
this kind of we're really disappointed
actually that we can do that but but yet
so that there are like a couple of other
candidates out there with 60 which have
a little bit less symmetry but they
don't work for other reasons can you
make bigger we can can you go bigger
yeah yeah so so there is one more thing
you can do which is 120 sided die I can
actually sort of explain how you do it
just looking at this so this has got 60
and as you say it's got too much
symmetry right there's this reflection
so what you do is you take each of these
you see these sort of kite shaped faces
and you divide it into two and you have
two little triangles on either side and
then you've gone from 6220 so we're
working on it
do you know about numberphile - that's
our second channel where there's bonus
footage and outtakes make sure you see
the extras from this video they're
really interesting so this is a skewed
version of the d12 which is similarly
weird and while you're there why not
subscribe to numberphile - that way
you'll know all about the extra stuff I
don't always mention here on the main
channel mirror symmetry which means that
of course we had to do both of them
right so we had to make two mirror image
pairs because I so I think to do right
you